hello welcome to this video playing see
Donnie - okay Scott check with my
special team scoring - well with it to
abandon the idea I'm flagging that light
so keep on doing it again I've got a
great position just win the pawn down
okay taking center pawns
I'm definitely good in yeah just trying
to be sound in solitaire see form is
maybe something that one can tribe he's
better better developed so maybe you
need something maybe this seems to
simplify matters a little bit okay I
thought it wouldn't work to be honest it
was all designed to prevent the smooth
hmm for like resins yeah that was a good
opening disaster
it starts with Bishop d3 that's already
not very good I mean yeah you know
you're not like losing but it just
doesn't belong on d3 if you want to play
for an opening advantage here you have
to play queen g4 in this position or go
one Knight f5 earlier yeah I mean oh
yeah you can also do it here this is
also possible but the thing is that here
a black is already quite fine 92 is of
course better than Queen a3 which just
loses the pawn but and something like
this is just absolutely nothing for
white like has a very good development
and no bad piece note that this is not
great
yeah this is just blundering the big
center pawn so much is this and I wasn't
sure I wanted to prevent c4 with this
and he played it anyway I'm not sure
what I expected maybe moving the night
somewhere or taking and he I felt that I
should be should be very fine it is just
the big center hall and that Knight is
not especially pretty so pretty pretty
quick win thanks for watching